[Music]
america
lost a legend today baseball's former
home run king hameron hank aaron died
overnight
at age 86. jackie robinson opened the
door for black major league baseball
players
but aaron busted it down after a short
stint in the negro leagues the mobile
alabama native
entered major league baseball with the
milwaukee braves in 1954.
the team would move to atlanta in 1966
over his 23-year career and aaron would
become one of the game's premier stars
raking up countless honors including a
world series title
and nvp award in 1957 but his crowning
achievement was breaking babe ruth's
career home run record
it happened on this swing in 1974.
much like jackie robinson three decades
earlier america's
ugly history of racism also affected
aaron
he received hate mail and death threats
as he chased ruth's record
today show anchor craig melvin talked to
aaron about that
in an interview last year
i was surprised to read in what should
have been
the most exciting period of your life
you're chasing babe ruth's record it
wasn't it was not
why not i couldn't go out of the
ballpark without
an escort i had to stay in another hotel
rather than staying in a hotel with my
teammates
it was the toughest moment of my life
joining me now is a man who interviewed
hank aaron several times over
the years mlv.com columnist mike lupica
is back with us first off it's just
amazing to think about the legacy of
hank aaron i grew up
with a dad um who loved hank aaron and
loves baseball so
um when i heard this news today i was
incredibly sad but give me a sense
of the impact of hank aaron and the
impact he had on baseball but also on
america
yeah that's the thing zulina you know
hank aaron i i tweeted this out today
um he was not just hank aaron great
baseball player
he was hank aaron great american this
was an extraordinary
american life i i wrote about this today
he was born two years into fdr's first
term
and lived long enough to see joe biden
get sworn into office
this week that's the stretch and the
scope of this man's life
he was a gentle strong elegant
graceful gifted person he played for the
indianapolis
clowns in the negro leagues for 200
a month in 1953. he said he had to make
a jar of peanut butter go a long
long way and then his original contract
got sold to the boston braves
for ten thousand dollars and and the
rest is a glorious history
of of of this sport but again this child
of mobile alabama
ended up breaking the record of babe
ruth in atlanta so a child of the south
and and when he talks about the hate
mail he got i spoke to bud selig today
his dear friend for 60 years the former
commissioner of baseball
he saw those letters and i asked mr
aaron one time
i said why did you keep him and he said
because they were part of my story
too and what part of what he told craig
today he
he not only had to sneak out of
ballparks when he's tracing
the most famous record in the history of
american sports he said he
slept in ballpark some nights just to be
safe
wow wow that's incredible um and you got
to interview him a few times just in the
last year
which is amazing i wanted to read a
quick quote from aaron that
struck me from your conversations he
said i was thinking later on when pete
rose was
trying to break ty cobb's all-time
record how much people love
pete and we're rooting for him i wish i
could have had
a little of that love what's your
reaction to that when you when you talk
about
the fact that he has to sleep in the in
the stadium
uh for his own safety you know it's such
a shame when you think about
other players later on in history that
uh
received accolades at the time they were
breaking records
yeah i mean it should have been a joyful
pageant
of american sports and the guy and he
said to me once
i didn't think of myself as trying to
break babe ruth's record
i was trying to set my own and
and and our last conversation four days
before christmas we were talking about
how
negro league um stats had now been added
to the history of baseball
and you know he only needed a handful to
have ended up with more than barry bonds
with later on
and he said tell them that if they can
find nine or ten home runs of mine
i'll i'll take them and he was he had
the most
wonderful disposition and selena you
know if
it's obvious that you've seen these
columns we had a long and i felt
important conversation about george
floyd in the shadow of the death
of george floyd and and imagine now
the the life hank aaron led and what he
had gone through
and he said at the time i'm frightened
for america this man was afraid of
nothing
he was afraid of nobody he said the
conversations
that he once had with his grandchildren
had come rushing back to him
and and at the end of one of those
columns he said to me
i don't get around much anymore he he
was in a wheelchair mostly for the last
few years of his life
and he said but if i could i'd be at the
front of those lines
and and i you know what he would have
been in the front of those lines
uh last spring when he thought there
might not be a baseball season
at the end of one of our conversations
had a really soft voice
he said god i love baseball and that was
the end of my column today for mlb
i said that was god's gift to baseball
talk into the world
in terms of you know how much he cared
about the community obviously you talked
to him
uh in the aftermath of george floyd but
also we showed earlier that his very
last
post on twitter was him getting the
vaccine really just trying to inspire
communities of color
to do the same why was it so important
for him
not just to be good at sports but to
also be a role model
for communities of color and and really
you know young kids writ large
he he was so profoundly blessed in his
mind that that
the lord had given him this talent to
play baseball that jackie robinson had
blazed the trail
for him in 1947 and and i can't tell you
how many times he told me
i believe it is my duty to pay it
forward he helped raise
millions of dollars for the united negro
college fund he
he was he was a he was a passionate
person about social justice
and again so much of the racism that we
see now
in this country he lived it in his
pursuit of
babe ruth 36 you know in 1974.
i mean it's it's it's it's it's
remarkable nothing that was happening in
this country
over the past couple of years surprised
him at all he knew from his own life
that race was and always would be the
third rail in this
in this country
do you feel like as you talked to him in
the last year
that he felt optimistic about the future
obviously it's hard to say because
uh you know donald trump was the
president for the last four years but
he did get to see at least you know a
little bit of a shift post
november and i feel like um you know
somebody who's lived through the
experiences that you just detailed
you know inside they are optimistic they
have to be to just continue to get up
every single day
uh and engage uh you know so uh
intensely in all of these issues
oh no he he he was talking about how
how excited he was again in the shadow
of the death of george floyd
how much he loved seeing kids in the
streets
white kids black kids he said it didn't
matter the color
social justice in in his mind at that
point didn't require
a a test to see what color you were and
so that he was
incredibly optimistic and again
i'm so glad he got to see last week
in baseball i i hope he was alert and
aware
and saw the way this country felt
at noon on wednesday when when joe biden
got sworn in
absolutely it was history uh seeing
kamala harris sworn in as well was
was it put a smile on so many faces
around the country because
of um a first you know it's hard to be a
first tank aaron and jackie robinson
prove that
um but it's so amazing when you get
there mike lupica thank you so much for
being here
um i was incredibly excited to have you
tonight
for this conversation even though it is
sad news it's important to reflect on an
uh incredible legacy
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching